como “Health Month” para la gente.
¿Por qué crea una cosa así?
Bueno, aquí hay un conjunto de axiomas
que Habit Labs, la empresa de Buster, presentó
sobre cómo querían trabajar juntos en equipo
cuando estaban construyendo estas aplicaciones
–un conjunto de principios morales establecidos por ellos mismos
para trabajar juntos–
y uno de ellos era:
“Nos preocupamos por nuestra propia salud y dirigimos nuestros ejercicios físicos”.
Porque en última instancia, ¿cómo pueden preguntarse
y encontrar una respuesta
sobre la visión de la buena vida
que quieren transmitir y crear con sus diseños
sin preguntarse
qué visión de la buena vida
les gustaría vivir?
Y con eso, les doy las gracias.
(Aplausos)